als nächsten youtube würde ich sagen
nehmt ihr kritiker zu einem neuen video
auf den bauch scheinen 80
heute mache meine auf den bau von 98 2
wurde als wir unsere leute waren wir
heute machen luca und machen youtube
anbieten gegen dann alles geht darum wer
nachmachen kann getreten und so kann ich
machen heute youtuber nach und max
entscheidet darüber werfen und bei
nämlich über wetter nach gemacht hat und
auch viel geld haben hey leute was geht
und ich begrüße ich hätte das geht nicht
mehr pablo und entkommen möchte zu einem
neuen video ja super leute anfangen dem
video erst mal mit peter verlosung kabel
400 millionen ich hoffe ich kann es
nicht glauben
die wirkung jeder luca rettete mich
geschlagen hat
gerade gesagt gehaben der wende bei
einer leiter die jury lobt und die
schlimmsten einschüchtern
was ein milieu wetter nach gemacht aber
kapitel aufgeschlagen
luca als nächste nehmen wir ein plan
diesmal beginnt fairerweise luca ist ein
schwerer abend sollte heute bei einem
neuen video versammeln denn wir haben
heute mal etwas wieder kleinen zu
besprechen und ich wurde sie dann werde
auch bei der straße angesprochen auf das
genannte niemals möglich wäre
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht okay
reagieren heute einfach mal drauf und
ich würde sagen meine damen und herren
damit einfach mal direkt an ich habe
werde jetzt auf die augen und auf die
dinge genau wie er redet und sie kommen
zu einem neuen video
viele von euch haben sich gefragt warum
ich schalte rede mein bier dazu man sie
etwas sagen das gerne wand voller
smileys hallo auch ein makler auch in
diesem video ist vielen dank fürs
zuschauen da fand ich war besser aber
immer noch rund natürlich dann steckt er
macht jetzt kennt damit nach empfängern
ich bin gut nachgemacht auf jeden fall
machen dann versetzte der punkt auf
jeden fall mark burg für alle leute bei
diesem wunderschönen nach fairen regen
gespielten spielen nach ihren regeln
leute mit ihnen abwehrt fairen regeln
spielen spielt der zweite teil weil ich
immer sehr fair
die punkte nicht bekommen haben dagegen
gute bekommen dann freue ich mich
nochmal alter vom standpunkt an markt
folgt dann die fünfte findet ihn
nachgemacht werden sei bitteschön die
vierte wurden
guten morgen punkt am markt würde sagen
dass neben alles klar
personen die heute nachgemacht wird
kontrakte das fängt an mit deutschland
herzen kommen zu meinem heutigen video
und dann will der vulkan war bereit
haben wir kommen zu einem neuen video
ich wollte ich einfach mal sagen ja
leute übrigens sind wieder neue
klamotten angekommen ich habe einfach
mal in lubmin ist vorbei ich wollte
wirklich sagen okay der punkt geht an
web bildet er wirklich gut gemacht mit
dem brand wird nach eine firma egbert
beschissen aber wir brechen das aber
darf man den punkt was besser gemacht
berlin oder kriegt vier punkte abzugeben
seine hand auf der weg vielleicht den
oberkörper immer damit 342 für mich
nicht alles täuscht und der herr die
versetzten neuen namen
so gerne ich mich wirklich okay anfang
[Musik]
gelacht computer wetter ist es nur fair
mit dem körper drückt er heute wieder
die mitgebracht
hier bin ich gehöre der champion von der
ja nicht hier bin ich mir der typ der
das war nicht hier bin ich mir der typ
der in guten 3 35 hat auch gut welche
besser lassen gleich in der beschreibung
der youtuber als würde ich sagen
kritiker
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
gerade elf zu drei viertel der leser
kann alles gemacht werden soll ist
bislang an miro leute was die da hab ich
bin ein relevanter mittdreißiger und
versuchte zum 20 das zeigt er wie du
deine freunde gefunden
die wird definitiv an apple meine
freunde wieder was im internet gefunden
für mich
das trumpf ass 30 15 spielern falsch
angesagt war federführend untersucht
werde das war natürlich okay alles klar
sehr gut dann würde ich da eigentlich
machen wir doch einfach mal ein paar der
bauunternehmer youtuber danach gemacht
wird ist in 4 21 er fängt an gucken
mittag oder auch drohten abend und
herzlich willkommen meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren über platz waren meine
ehrenvoll leiterin von bright direkt dem
hintergrund der vom kläger megacool
imitiert genau durchlade seine videos
und beendet seine video rauch würde
sagen daher steht dem freien und 20%
sich vermacht alle starter mit jetzt 30
geführt sich logischerweise ich würde
sagen der nicht-jüdische der nächste
youtube jemand wie man so gar nicht auf
dem schirm
man weiß nicht ob man eben wirklich gut
nachmachen kann hat stacheln ich würde
auf jeden fall sagen der goldgräber zwei
bäcker anfängen in bewegung angeführt
und her kommt wollten dabei besteht
jetzt auf jeden fall schon mal 23 39
wachst du fängst an wert verliert apple
dran auch sehr gut denn ich würde sagen
die liga besser an mark garrett oder 30
23 gewonnen
danke fürs zuschauen ich bin auf jeden
fall war